filipinos packed malls and shopping
districts during the holidays as cases
of kovit 19 appeared to be dropping to
new lows
the government had eased most
restrictions ahead one of the busiest
seasons but experts warned there was no
room for complacency starting december
19
we we somehow uh
had an alarm alert that there's already
like a switch of trend you know and the
increase in the positivity rate is very
very fast and
in terms of patterns we see that most of
the cases currently are asymptomatic and
mild and they are coming from the
uh
20s 30s age group so somehow uh somehow
we can correlate this this kind of
dynamics to mobility of people because
of the
holidays more omicron patients have been
identified this week by the health
department while a traveler from the
united states who tested positive had
reached quarantine regulations in order
to party
at least a dozen of her close contacts
now have the virus
the endocrine variant is driving cold
bit 19 cases to record numbers in many
countries the philippines has largely
been spared but daily infections are on
the rise and while it's possible the new
virus variant is spreading
health department officials say it's too
early to make that conclusion
a new wave of the virus is likely not
only to strain the country's health care
system it could exacerbate the
humanitarian crisis in regions still
suffering from the impact of super
typhoon rai
as it is there are already outbreaks of
diarrhea and gastroenteritis in those
areas worst hit by the storm
we haven't received official report
except for
increase of cases in diarrhea cough and
cold
but but you know cough and cold um is
are among the symptoms closely monitored
for kovi there are no partition or
division in the evacuation center so um
covid is an airborne
disease in such as that it can easily
also
spread
aid workers hoped an increase in kovid19
cases would be the last thing they would
have to deal with as they are still
struggling to provide basic needs like
food and clean drinking water to the
millions affected by the typhoon
barn below al jazeera manila